Okay,
should be live. Let me set the title.
All right, that should be good.
Um,
short stream
on a crappy morning.
I just [clears throat]
felt like streaming a little bit of this
refactoring work.
Well, hang on.
This need to be here.
depends on puff roll should just be in
there.
We're getting closer, I'd say.
One, two, three.
Uh, okay.
Welcome
Yeah. So, we have to we have to route
this a little differently, right?
There's got to be some sort of shared
thing. No,
it's the wrong split because this
shouldn't be here, right?
Hey, Jess. Yeah, pretty much.
I mean, it's going to take a while,
right?
That nice out. This is just my normal
jacket.
Also, I have the camera angled weird. I
always do this where I'm like
super low on the screen, but whatever.
It's cuz if I actually sit up for
meetings now, I'm centered, but like I'm
not going to do that working all day.
To be fair, this is my this is like the
uh my favorite jacket I've ever gotten.
Um
it's from uh Vory.
It's the only place where I actually
like getting stuff. It's just like
really really comfortable hybrid
athletic wear.
enough fun with Codeex. Yeah. Nothing
but joy, I'll tell you.
I mean, I there's still quite a bit of
we can clean up.
Yeah. So that's the whole reason for
having this Jess.
That's why Puffer's been able to do
stuff so fast.
We invested in the
those really really fast tests.
you know, like the jacks people have
minotaur and whatever, but that's really
first of all, it's much slower and
second of all, you can't just make the
task arbitrarily easy
and still get meaningful results.
There's a threshold above which you have
to
We do have your uh your latest stuff
pulled in now. It's pretty nice. I'll
show you.
Oops.
Too many files, too much code. But this
is down like minus 10 files and minus
1,200 lines since yesterday
or during yesterday I should I haven't
done much yet today.
49K.
Where do you see 49K?
That's not lines. That's characters,
dude. It's 1300 lines by 13,000 lines.
To be fair, the line count thing is not
great. Um,
and I've kind of wanted to just make
like a basic tokenizer at some point.
I think you could get a much more
accurate count of the code size if you
just count like symbols separately.
Not like LM tokens. That's different.
But you know, every operator
Yeah. So, I already did that, man. I
haven't done uh I have not done any
edits to it otherwise, but the GP is
merged into one file and then the
proteins merged into one file. So, I
took your four and I put them in two.
I also I deleted the like the
polymorphic
weird interface for supporting lots of
different kernels since we don't need
that but I haven't really uh refactored
anything else yet.
So protein now is total
Certain estimate for the acquisition
functions is a chance the variance was
crap. The coariance kernel wasn't a good
fit.
That could be the case.
But then glitzy like
you kind of have to test it across a
bunch of different problems unless we're
going to come up with ways to make um
like very strong guarantees about the
type of data that you put into these
things.
that was um inherited from carbs. I
think I tried a couple things, but it
did seem you needed the linear plus
return.
I wouldn't be surprised ends up being
shorter.
Let's see. I honestly I'm going to be
honest. I have no idea. I do not have
the background to make sense of that.
I have no idea how different it is from
just like a Gaussian plus linear
or I mean that poly was it poly plus
linear that doesn't make sense.
This is separate.
We know this will go away.
I mean, like that's kind of the ideal
background for you, let's say. Um,
and the goal is basically to figure out
whether this is the right approach. From
what everything I see, it seems like the
only thing that actually makes sense for
hyperparam
is um, Gaussian process,
what form of it makes sense, and then
what's the simplest way that we can use
it that's going to actually be robust
across all the different ends and not
have any like stupid edge cases to it,
right?
See, that's not at all how I was
introduced to Gaussian processes.
See, I was introduced to them as just
putting a bump everywhere that you have
existing data.
and that being useful because what the
heck else do you do when you have 50
data points in R50
and then linear is like are you going is
gives you a a prior that you extrapolate
linearly globally where some of the
functions are more Vocal
You kind of just have to test all this
stuff empirically, don't you?
Nice thing. Well, nice thing is they
have um they have closed form solutions,
right?
uh note that we don't really have to
care about learning rate free.
It's nice, but that's like nowhere near
as big of a deal as just given schedule
free to work.
Proctor and Puffer would use CNN
right out of the box bufferet.
So it depends.
If you're going to put the pixel data
in, then you need a convenencer.
If you check out the entity gem blog
post by Clemens Winter, he has a
tilebased encoding,
I think derived from state. I think that
if you use the tilebased encoding, you
wouldn't need coms.
Like they might still help in samples,
but you can probably just solve it in
wall clock without
Isaac sim or go to RL.
Neither.
Both of those are trolling.
Both of those are talking like minimum
four orders of magnitude slower than
puffer.
Torch isn't terrible glitzy. It's the
second best thing.
It's a bad implementation of a good
design
at the very least.
That's something.
Let me see what else we want to merge
here
for small neural nets with RL. Yes, it's
literally C and CUDA. The good news is
we've kind of already done it for you
and it's really not that hard.
Like we the entirety of Puffer is less
code than a lot of the um really bulky
annoying robotics code bases or RL and
even some of the game RL code bases
like this is just logging. This is like
visualization.
This is hyperparameter sweep. The core
is 5K lines.
And you see the amount of effort that I
put into like cutting it down, cutting
it down, trying to make it simpler and
simpler, right?
What choice do I have? Yeah. So, that's
the It depends on your timelines, right?
And your skill levels.
Um
I think that the if you don't want to do
everything fully fully from scratch,
you'd basically just grab um warp
like do stuff around warp in the
simplest way you can still in C or CUDA
and then bind it to existing puffer for
training. That's probably your best bet
instead of fully fully re-implementing
everything.
But if it's like, oh well, I don't
really do systems or I don't really like
how do I just do this fast in Python?
You you don't. That's the thing. There's
just no way to do that.
Like, sorry. The um the tool stack that
the field uses is just the wrong one.
That's why they haven't made enough
progress in the last several years.
They've kind of just all
they've all sort of um agreed upon a bad
tool stack. That's just what happens.
And it's very hard to recognize because
you really really have to replace a lot
of stuff before this becomes obvious.
But then you can look at the speeds we
get in Puffer and you go, "Oh yeah,
that's why."
Right?
Yeah, let's see. The um contributions to
hyper pram sweep are tremendously
useful.
The thing is like you can't just say,
"Oh, C++ good." C++ is like at least has
the potential to be good, but usually
people make a mess of it.
Yeah. But I the more I've sort of done
stuff in RL, the more I've realized it's
just not worth it to try to work around
the existing infrastructure.
You'll just waste years of your life.
That's not what I said. FBR. I said that
there was a project that was adjacent
but using them in a different way.
It's sort of on holdish. Parts of it
made it into Puffer 5 um into Puffer 5
though
where I guess Puffer 5 and six are
getting swapped now. But there was some
initial promising results.
stuff calculation from hand to
understand them.
I will say neuro um the good news with
puffer it's very very accessible
like the tools we use it's just loops
and conditionals over data in static
memory like if you read our code it's
first year undergraduate level systems
code most of it
and all the CUDA is basically the same
there's very very little that's hard to
get into now the rationale for
everything and how I came up with this
specific architecture that takes years
of experience to actually look at what
we're doing and understand what it is
and how it works very accessible
I don't know why I'm stalled here so
badly here. I just want to know what we
can merge.
So this is kept because this gets used
by
how many different compilation units do
we have here?
One,
two,
three.
Three compilation units.
I don't know if that can be made fast.
Glitzy,
I think that the most important thing is
just making protein itself better. like
take fewer samples.
um
have fewer degeneracies.
But for six, just the algorithm
improvements, Jess, that are likely
going to get um
I'd like to ship something at the end of
the summer here. So,
max plus one month because the client
work. I just don't want another very
long update.
I don't like this kernels file.
But I think it's mostly just the
If we drain some of stuff in Puffer, it
can merge to dashboard.
Ops
Fox 3D.
Let's see. Um,
so possibly. I will tell you though, the
the one end that somebody tried to make
with box 2D ended up being like the
biggest PR ever, way longer than it
should have been, and having major
performance issues to the point that
it's not even like commonly used at the
moment.
Now, if you want to go clean up Impulse
Wars, it's on the website. It's an
awesome end, but like it was so slow
because of the box 2D dep.
And we've not had this issue in any
other end since that we've just done
with uh no engine.
2D robot arm.
Oh yeah, physics is definitely a badass.
But the question is not whether it's a
bit ass. The question is, is it worse
than
dealing with the damn engine?
custom physics sim.
Yeah, honestly could be, but it wouldn't
be that type of physics sim.
Much more interested in like molecular
level physics.
Honestly, I'm happy with everything
else.
I think the main thing is the colonel's
file.
I mean the most base thing to do right
now would be to merge advantage kernels
loss model
like just merge and puffer into a like a
four to 5,000line
single file implementation.
I don't think that's the play, but it
would be funny.
It's also not terrible, actually. That's
nowhere near as bad as it would as you
would think. Hey, Liberty.
Maybe it is actually. Let's see.
as prow.
No, because see this is kind of still
Wait, how's this not include anything?
Oh, because it gets include. Okay.
I mean, I do kind of like the idea in
the sense that we know how long our full
trainer is
and it becomes a much more easy explicit
target.
That is one way to not have to fiddle
about um
I wonder what is stopping me from doing
that.
It's kind of troll, but it's kind of
not.
If it's under 5k, we consider
let's say 200 from kernels.
I am genuinely thinking like
do we just merge all the core files and
then aggressively simplify
convert I don't know
from the archive title What paper that
is
We're not going to do this now before we
commit. Obviously.
I think it's worth at least trying out.
What time is it? It's 1:36.
I think I have to chat with Spencer
first. Let me see.
merging like half of these files.
I'm trying to think like what happens if
we just aggressively merge um the entire
backend into one file
like the whole trainer
and then we end up with maybe like a
total of less than 10 files
like
so we'd basically just end up with
buffer
Puffer lib sweep
probably like this anything
eval
constellation maybe
be very minimal.
Well, I like the one thing I really
really like about having um
one file makes it very very obvious when
you're bloating stuff.
Otherwise, plus 20 lines here, plus 20
lines there.
We'll probably make this puff RL.CU as
well.
That's a lot less bullshitting over what
should live where, right? It also just
solves that problem.
You sort of just end up pouring code
back and forth until you have it right.
Beck and
probably Beck and gets
eight tabs open.
Absolutely.
This is just other crap. I have one open
right now, which is arguably one too
many.
This is a very, very large and obnoxious
refactor though.
I mean, my initial goal is if I can just
with codeex get the code that should go
in each file to be in the correct files
so I'm happy with the structure,
then I start going through and with
codeex again fixing obviously stupid
things. Then I go in manually and fix
the smaller things.
That's the idea.
All right, I'm going to call it here
though because I have uh I got a meeting
that I got to get ready for
and
might be back later this afternoon,
probably tomorrow, though. For anybody
new around here, Star Puffer on GitHub.
It's all free and open source. I'm going
to finish this uh refactor up over the
next few days, at least the first pass
of it.